[Music]
hello there October 2023 may go down in
history as the greatest ever month for
video games from the AAA Blockbuster
sequels to a shed load of free-to-play
games and everything in between here's
so many games you won't have time to
play them all
as if I could start anywhere else
Spider-Man 2. the PS5 exclusive picks up
the story of Peter Parker and his
Protege Miles Morales this action
adventure takes everything from the
previous games and doubles down with two
playable Spider-Man to freely switch
between the map is now twice the size
and a couple of whole new ability lists
thanks to miles's evolving bioelectric
powers and Peter's run in with the Venom
symbiote web swinging has been added to
with web Wings a glider of sorts that
lets Spider-Man navigate the open world
three times faster than the previous
games we've already seen a dozen super
villains in the demos and trailers
including lizard Craven and of course
Venom himself Spider-Man 2 looks to be
unmissable and releases on October 20th
only on the PS5 and my channel this
month will be almost totally dedicated
to Spider-Man 2 starting with some story
Recaps next week so please drop by
October the 20th can't come soon enough
[Music]
another huge game dropping in October is
Assassin's Creed Mirage this will be the
13th Mainline game and almost another 20
spin-off titles too over the last decade
the stealth and finesse of the original
Assassin's Creed games was rejected and
replaced with an open world sprawling
RPG and that's where Mirage realigns
things this is in fact a smaller more
linear game akin to The Originals we are
going back to 9th century Baghdad as
bassim and his journey through life from
Street Thief to full member of the
Assassin's Brotherhood the hidden blade
and that Stealth gameplay return as the
core mechanics and so too back is
intricate parkour sections Assassin's
Creed Mirage will not ask for 100 plus
hours of your time instead somewhere
around 20 hours for a standard gamer and
about 30 for the completionists out
there Mirage hits PlayStation's Xboxes
and PC on October 5th
next another sequel Alan Wake 2 a
survival horror game from the Brilliant
Minds at remedy the premise is an
interesting one as a horror novelist
finds himself trapped in a world just
like those he writes in his books Alan's
been here for 13 years now and has
become this grizzled John Wick looking
dude with the ability to write the rules
of the world he lives in the survival
horror nature of Alan Wake 2 is cut into
two single-player stories with the
player deciding which to undertake first
that includes playing as Saga Anderson
an FBI agent who plays slightly
differently to Alan Wake as she sleuths
her way through many puzzles and pieces
of detective work Alan Wake 2 is here in
time for Halloween on October 27th on
Playstation Xbox series and PC
[Music]
another Juggernaut of a game is Lords of
the Fallen a successor and reboot of
sorts to the 2014 game with the exact
same name Lords of the Fallen is the
souls like game of the month a third
person punishing action role-playing
game where failure is an expect rotation
and slowly learning to understand boss
movements is the draw with perfect
parrying and dodging the key skill
needed all leading to the immense
feeling of defeating a boss on the 25th
time of asking as you can see the
aesthetic is gothic horror and it
definitely challenges Elden ring for the
best visuals in this genre Lords of the
Fallen also supports co-op gameplay with
a friend and of course the bolted on PVP
mode that tends to come with these sorts
of games October 13th is a release day
on PS4 Xbox series and PC
so those are the heavy hitting games of
October and now we have some free games
and holy heck there is so many free
experiences that are pretty high
standard this month starting with we
were here Expeditions the Friendship
this game is free to download and keep
as long as you do so before October 13th
after that it goes back up to its normal
price this is a two-player Cooperative
Puzzler where communication is Paramount
the Friendship is a cut down bite-sized
version of the Fuller we were here games
and this one takes about two hours to
complete with a very attainable platinum
trophy on Playstation I played this with
a friend on PC and it worked seamlessly
even though he couldn't stop shredding
golden tickets a great little Puzzler
totally free for now if you're quick
enough on Playstation Xbox and PC but
you only have until October 13th to
claim this
[Music]
next is finally here my hero Ultra
Rumble a battle royale unlike the others
24 players take the field each in eight
teams of three characters with a simple
goal of being the last Squad standing we
can play as hero or villain and a
constant stream of new characters from
the my hero Academia series will be
added each with their own abilities
making finding the perfect Synergy of
three characters the likely difference
between winning and losing customization
is a big part of the game with the
ability to change costumes and to
personalize your emotes as this is free
to play that's where the
microtransactions will generally be
surprisingly this is technically a last
gen game releasing on PS4 switch Xbox
One and PC but backwards compatibility
makes it completely playable on PS5 and
Xbox series my hero Ultra Rumble is here
in September on the 28th literally three
days after I post this video and a
reminder about a game we looked at last
month Disney's speedstorm September 28th
is also the full launch date of that
cart racer packed with many of those
iconic characters you watched throughout
your entire life
[Music]
another free game this month is Roblox
if finally came to PlayStation 4 after
17 years Roblox is no longer classed as
a game it's an online platform itself
which became the home of unique and
creative custom games I've never played
Roblox but looking at some of the games
created this is honestly amazing every
genre imaginable like this this was made
in Roblox how is that possible Roblox
comes to PS4 on October 10th if you have
any Maps you recommend please throw them
in the comments thank you and wait
there's more honkai star rail makes its
way onto PlayStation 5 on October 11th
from the very rich creators of genjin
impact comes a different take on that
formula space fantasy the combat system
is the most change aspect When comparing
genjin to Star rail as turn-based combat
replaces the organic hack and slash
method effectively making honkai star
rail most like a traditional jrpg made
in China honkai is indeed a gacha game a
chance of drops is offered and
officially honkai star rail is classed
as ungenerous which means the sorts of
items you want will always be extremely
difficult to acquire and that's where
monetization comes in although it is
possible to build a quite impressive
free-to-play team
[Music]
and oh my gosh we have another free to
play game X defiant the Challenger to
Call of Duty's multiplayer scene was set
to come out over summer but both
PlayStation and Xbox rejected the first
attempt which is quite normal and extra
violence game director has said that the
second attempt to pass certification is
already in and now he hopes for the game
to release around the 15th of October as
this is not set in stone I'll cover this
in more depth next month just know it's
a class-based shooter with each
character having their own ability on a
cooldown
[Music]
games and do this as a speed round
because there's too many games this
month ghost Runner 2 the follow-up to
the hardcore action title in which a
single bullet can't stop your entire run
releases on October 26th perfecting a
path through the countless enemies
carving them into pieces as you pass is
one of the most satisfying feelings in
gaming if a little dark too ghost Runner
2 is a difficult game and therefore a
demo is already out right now you can
play it to see if speed running with a
giant sword in your hand is your kind of
thing full game drops on October 26th on
PS5 Xbox series and PC the Retro return
of Sonic the Hedgehog is coming in Sonic
Superstars the iconic speed platformer
returns to its Sega Mega Drive and
Genesis root but with a much needed
visual upgrade we play a Sonic Tails
Knuckles or Amy and race to fight
Robotnik and Fang the sniper with new
ability zones and mini-games to play
through Superstars could be the Sonic
game we've been wanting since Sonic
Mania back in 2017. Sonic Superstars is
both single and multiplayer and releases
on October 17th on the PlayStations the
Xboxes the PC and the switch if racer is
your jam you be sure to check out Hot
Wheels Unleashed 2 turbocharged the
original game came out of nowhere and
quickly established itself as a solid
racer that Embraces velocity through
collectible toy cars speeding through
oversized rooms as a tiny toy car and
bike may be a gimmick but it works look
out for the sequel on October 19th on
Playstation Xbox PC and twitch and one
more Blast from the Past a collection of
games in fact this is the Metal Gear
Solid Master collection Konami has
smashed together a bunch of the earlier
Metal Gear games including the solid
Trilogy and the early MSX games this
most renowned in gaming history but the
technical specs suggest not every game
in this bundle has received the same
level of care so maybe wait for reviews
before picking this one up there are so
many games coming this month that I
can't fit them into a video not to
mention the new Mario and forza games on
other platforms October 2023 may go down
in history as the greatest month ever in
video games okay I'm sure you're sick of
My Voice by now so I'll get out of your
ear holes but first take a few dad jokes
how do you get 20 Pikachus onto a
jam-packed train you Pokemon one mile
for the road why did the T-Rex break up
with his girlfriend
because his ex stinked yeah that's bad
sorry I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see
you next time
foreign